(upbeat jazz music)
- You look so sharp.
- Thank you.
- Our shoes kind of match,
like the color scheme.
We called each each other.
- But you know.
- Yeah, these are new.
That's the only reason why they're not.
Have y'all met before?
I don't know if y'all met.
- Okay, so technically, yes.
- Wait, really?
(laughing)
- Technically.
- Ooh, I'm busted.
When was that?
- I was a child actor in New
York and I did your show.
It was a bit or a-
- [Kelly] What!?
- Sketch or something.
I can't remember what it-
- Trick or treating, maybe?
- Something like that.
And I did your show and I
was like seven or eight.
- Aw!
- So technically, yes.
(audience applauding)
There's no way you should remember that.
- You look the same.
You look just the same.
- I remember like it was yesterday.
That's amazing, at seven years old, wow.
- Yeah, Yeah.
- Were you terrified being like that young
like doing stuff like this?
I would've been terrified.
- I was a very serious child.
- [Kelly] Oh really?
- A very serious child. I was at work-
- [Kelly] You've always been that way?
- I knew what I was doing.
I was here to build my career.
I was getting started where I could.
- [Rosie] Wow!
- So, thank you
for one of my first jobs.
- You are welcome.
- [Kelly] Wow.
(audience laughing)
But you, you both worked
with Shirley Ralph, right?
- Who I adore.
- Yeah?
- The great, the great Shirley Ralph.
- [Rosie] She is something else.
(audience applauding)
- [Tyler] Yeah.
- [Rosie] And I got to see her
in Dream Girls on Broadway.
- You did?
- I did, more than once
because that was the best show
I've ever seen in my life.
- Oh, I love that feeling.
- And then she was the,
we were in the Flintstones together.
She ran the adoption
agency that got me Bam Bam.
So we've been friends for
a long time and I love her.
I'm so happy she's getting
her, her rewards now.
- [Tyler] Oh, so am I, so am I.
- Yeah. You have the same experience?
What does she, what does she mean to you?
- So Sheryl and I actually
go back pretty far.
My baby brother, also a child actor,
did a show with her called Instant Mom,
for four years.
So I met Cheryl, I think back in like 2014
or something like that.
And she was just so great with him
teaching him how to you know,
cut his teeth in the multi-cam world.
And she was just one
of those people who was a
constant in my life, at one point.
So to now do a show with her
and to watch everyone
realize the magnitude
of who she's and watch her get her flowers
in that way-
- Yeah
- Has been a long time coming for me.
I'm so happy that I could
even be a part of that.
- Well, so you're now in season two
of Abbot Elementary. So
what's new this year?
What's happening?
Other than finding things in closets?
- Well, as you can see in that scene
we are exploring more of the world, right?
We're going more into the
basement of the school
which is as terrifying as you think it is.
And going outside of the school,
getting into Philly,
understanding their personal lives.
And we're really seeing,
for the first time,
these teachers start a school year.
And then what that process is like.
We picked up mid-school year, last year
and this time we wanted
to really take it slow
and show people some of the things
that they didn't know happened
before your kids arrive.
- [Kelly] Which is really
relevant right now cuz
I think people really got a good grasp
of what it's like with Zoom school.
You know, all the parents having to-
- [Tyler] Oh, yes.
- Yeah, cuz people always complaining like
"Oh I have to do this with my kids."
I'm like, "Great."
The teacher's been doing it for years,
with like 30 of 'em.
- Years.
- Yeah.
- You had two.
- I still don't understand
that as a concept.
Cuz I have, I think on set,
about 15 to 20 kids in my class
and just trying to get them all quiet
to start rolling.
- That's what I'm saying.
- Yeah.
- It's like herding cats.
- And then someone has to
go to the bathroom and now
we all have to go to the bathroom.
But not at the same time.
So it's like, I'm realizing
how much this job is,
for a teacher, and how much that,
what an undertaking that is.
And to have kids that aren't your own.
- Yeah.
- You know, when people
are doing the Zoom,
at least they're your
kids, you know what I mean?
You know them.
- Right.
- But the teachers take it home too.
- Yeah.
- Yeah. I would've been a teacher
had I not done this.
- [Kelly and Tyler] Really?
- For sure.
- [Kelly] Oh you love children-
- I love it.
I would've wanna go in
the third grade, you know
the second grade, the first grade, even.
And people are like, what are you crazy.
The same way I always
wanted to have twins.
And people who have twins go,
"What are you crazy,
you don't want twins!"
But I felt like the more,
the better, you know?
So I have five and that's what happened.
- [Tyler] Yeah.
(audience laughing)
- So is it true that you
have to be careful what
you text Quinta?
Like does...
I have to be careful what I text
Blake Shelton, on the Voice.
- [Tyler] Really?
- Yeah. Cause he, he
probably put it out there.
- Okay. So great.
We have the same situ-
Yeah.
So, she will read me to
filth in the scripts.
(laughing)
And like I'm reading it and I'm like,
we literally just talked about this,
(audience laughing)
like there's a line in the first episode
of this season and we were talking
about all the different ways, you know,
things could go well
cause you were going into an award season
and I'm like, "I have contingency plans
for every possible reality."
And next thing I know,
it's in the script of like,
"One of the best things I'm
good at is making a plan
for something to go bad."
So she'll like actively
pull things from life
and throw them in there.
I really have to now just watch
cause I'm hoping like
none of like dating stuff
gets in there or anything like that.
(laughing)
- I'm really hoping it makes it
- I'm really hoping it's not.
- It feels, it feels interesting
cuz you're such a serious person.
It feels like a lot of
things are probably funny.
- Yes. Yes there are.
And she's good at
like really working that into the script.
- I love that, we're inspired.
Yeah. Art is inspired by life.
- Yes.
- That's not her fault.
So we need another commercial break y'all.
But would you like to
shoot a Kush Ball is-
- I would love to.
I've never
- You never done it?
- You what's-
(audience cheering)
- Wait.
- Okay.
- Pull.
- All right.
- Get it out of this little thing.
- There you go.
Now aim it someone you like.
- I'm so sorry.
(bowwww)
- There you go!
- Hey, you caught it!
(audience applauding)
- There we go.